and the Oscar goes to Matthew
mccon I remember not having any speech
it would be a bit of arrogance or a Cuda
gr to have something written I was like
no that's not for me to do that's a
little
presumptuous first off I want to thank
God because that's who I look up to to
my
family that's who and what I look
forward
to and to um my hero that's who I chase
I'm chasing me in 10 years my heroes me
in 10 years that's a form of the first
one of someone to look up to but it's
for me it's the Mortal version of who am
I going to become my hero is always 10
years away I'm never going to be my hero
I'm not going to attain that I know I'm
not and that's just fine with me cuz
that keeps me with somebody to keep on
chasing to those three things I say all
right all right all right all right all
right all
right thank
you